bienvenue dans la société la société est
une chaîne de sciences sociales avec un
peu geographic matière que j'enseigne au
collège station la berlière ces deux as
out 1 en belgique en belgique itway
initialement cette chaîne était destiné
à mes élèves pour la réalisation de
classe inversée mais aujourd'hui la
société qu'est devenue une chaîne
accessible à tous les élèves
francophones qui souhaitent découvrir
les sciences sociales et la géographie
de plus en plus je partage mon
expérience dans les pédagogies actives
qui utilise le numérique les stratégies
collaboratif cette partie la société qui
est plutôt destiné aux enseignants qui
souhaitent faire évoluer leurs pratiques
sociales
cette chaîne est organisé en différentes
playlist qui vous permette directement
d'arriver au contenu qui vous appelle
auteur de science sociale plutôt en
géographie vidéo sur le terrain méthodes
des sciences sociales
vous trouverez facilement ce que vous
cherchez en complément à cette chaîne un
blog et une page facebook au nom de la
société vous propose des contenus utiles
à la pratique des sciences sociales
chinoises
si vous souhaitez ne rien manquer
d'asociaux tech abonnez-vous et activer
la coche et à très bientôt sur la
société
[Musique]